the social bus fire of a world we live
in this is the show we should all be
watching and if by the end of this video
you don't feel that way fine you should
watch this video then watch square I
[Music]
queer I so queer is a show on Netflix as
essentially he's picking up the mantle
from the show Queer Eye for the straight
guy and they were like well I guess
that's a stigma granted if there's a
stigma about me I want it to be
unfashionable and although the very
fashionable fab 5 are all gay they're
just straight people that need help
straight gay trans they help many people
and that's what the show is these 5 go
around to people in Georgia that need
their help maybe they don't have fashion
sense maybe they don't know how to cook
maybe they look unkempt maybe they're
grown adults and their place looks like
a kid lives there in most cases it's all
of the above everyone in the show has
their place they have their thing that
they teach people tans fashion whether
it be a suit or casual wear that looks
nice I can't get my french tucked to
work as well as he does or as well as
anyone who he helps does I call a French
fish tuck but damn and I'm learning
Cantonese the food guy I now know how to
make guacamole like a [ __ ] and
tell you that Jonathan's the hair
stylist does hair that's beer Jonathan I
feel like Jonathan's wrong those ones
you use his name to describe him like
Jonathan Jonathan he's eccentric he's
energetic he apologizes for none of it
that's what I love about it but he just
owns it like he said he's like just own
it like Tyrion Lannister said wear it
like armor can never be used to hurt you
the transformations he does man I
haven't seen transformations like this
since beauty and the geek you remember
that show transformations were business
now Jonathan doesn't lobby works on the
living space he's interior decorating
I'm glad in season two Bobby got a
little more shine I felt like in season
1 Bobby just kind of got pushed to the
background cuz dealt with the person so
much and they're out there dealing with
the person they're buying suits and
meanwhile Bobby's working on the living
space in the house and they come back
and Bobby's like hey I transformed your
house pay so I'm glad in season 2 you
got a little more of who Bobby is you
didn't get so pushed into the background
since season 1 I was kind of indifferent
to Bobby a bum me out Susan to you you
get more of who he is that's important
in a show like this and Kurama for the
longest time I was like what does Carano
do does it just give motivational
speeches he does that's his thing he's
the culture guy which means they take a
ride with me I'll give you motivational
speeches but he has such good insight it
doesn't even end on the show you follow
him on Instagram you'll get you'll get a
motivational speech there what are the
videos you put on Instagram and gave
relationship advice I was like that's
[ __ ] solid relationship advice how
people live how people eat how they
express themselves how they dress it's
all interconnected
to making the best you possible girl
after watching a couple episodes of this
show I looked around in my place I was
like I need to unpack your pad all of
this length walls blinds a lot of the
walls are still blank
I got curtains now and a neat little
display for my records not gonna take
all that credit girlfriend definitely
helped me out on that which shows that
for a lot of people a lot of us out
there we can't do it alone
but what this show does the most
important thing it does it just brings a
ray of positivity to the world you look
at social media you look at Twitter you
look at Facebook all of its designed to
create argument how on earth can you
actually have a conversation at 140 or
280 characters at a time you can't you
jab you pull back they jab they pull
back there's no real conversation
happening there and lines have been
drawn and each sides fighting each side
it's crazy out there it's like this show
the producers the cast the five they'll
have this idea in their head they're
like let's just fight the negativity
with positivity let's bring a little
light into the world it's pretty much
like that Michael Jackson song you know
heal the world make it a better place
yeah those are my moves whatever it's
like the basis of that song drawn into a
show there's actually a great episode
this show takes place in Georgia I don't
know where all of them are from they
seem very Hollywood Khurram was driving
car um was black they get pulled over by
a cop so initially Curran was like I'm a
black guy got pulled over by a cop go
figure
turns out the cop is the one that called
them out to help his friend so later on
Kurama and the cop have a conversation
about cops black people tension I'll say
that again and hold on to your tweets
they had a conversation this is episode
where Anthony was talking about coming
out and he's tearing up and he's like
not everyone has that family that
accepts them and you're like oh my god
he lost people and it's crushing he's
not a good thing that pain happens pain
is a reality of life we have pain when
people show you their pain they show you
more of them I just appreciated that he
showed us that and I don't know him so
maybe he didn't lose anybody but that
scenario definitely hit him hard as I
just I appreciated that it was shown
it's very real moment he's not the only
one Karim Oh Bobby with the church in
these episodes you get the glimpses of
the pain of the past of members of the
cast it's just that that's very real it
keeps the show from being too high happy
all the time unrealistic and it's high
happy because we're choosing to be but
we recognize that there's pain in the
world somewhere among the episodes there
will be an episode that will bring you
at least almost to tears if you don't
actually break down to tears you'll have
a knot in your throat and be like mmm
I'm not crying you're crying actually I
think that's on the poster and above all
it looks like the fab 5 have a fun time
doing it like they're having fun you're
having fun watching it it's one of those
shows when it's over you're like damn it
I want more now and in a world of social
and political tension I like how they
dealt with some of the Trump supporters
I had on the show a couple of people for
sure in the show they voted for Trump I
would venture to guess a few more I mean
not everyone dad there were definitely
some Democrats some liberals on the show
that's the point of the show it just is
an array of people but they're in the
backwoods of Georgia they're gonna have
a future of supporters on there but they
didn't boil the quality of the character
of the people they were dealing with
down to who they voted for most of the
time they don't talk politics at all in
the show no I just appreciate the fact
that you have these five guys none of
which are fans of Donald Trump back from
where they're coming from they have
every reason to hate the guy but they
didn't put his voters into the Trump
basket people who voted for him are
different human beings I appreciated the
fact that this show at least appreciated
that they treated people on the opposite
end of the political spectrum as human
beings let me give you a cheat code for
conversation that's all people want now
that you have the cheat code feel free
to use it I bring this up because I feel
like I have fans who lean right and
there might be a stigma like you feel
like the show's gonna call you an
[ __ ] if you watch it and it won't no
matter who you are there's something in
this show for you that's what I'm
talking about when I say the show is
full of positivity it's full of
understanding understanding that talking
with a sword isn't talking at all you
can have a conversation and both learn
from it it's like these are the type of
dudes that will try to change your life
but not make you feel like you're less
they have that ability to walk
shoulder-to-shoulder with the people
they're helping and they don't make
those people feel like less that's true
humbleness that's true humility that's
true strength I know I'm just really
attached to this show I watched season 1
I immediately was like how could I
better my life is one of those shows
that causes self-reflection and I really
appreciate that and it's comprised of
people that apparently have the concept
of to make real change and to help heal
this busted-up social world you don't do
it by fighting you can make change with
positivity I think this is a really
important message in this day and age
we're so queer I have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you
[Music]